The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we will have
weekly quiz tomorrow.
There's been a lot of coverage,
and so to focus you
a bit, I'm going to confine the
weekly quiz to glasses and
chemical kinetics.
So you don't have to worry
about diffusion.
We'll catch up on that,
but I know there's so
much material there.
Let's keep it confined to
glasses and chemical kinetics.
And I'll be available
today 4:30 to 5:30.
If you can't be at that time,
send me a note, and I'm sure
we can figure out a time
to get together.
So what I want to do today
is to start a new unit.
We're going to start talking
today about solutions, and do
some solution chemistry, OK?
Today we talk about solutions.
And you might initially
say, why are we
talking about solutions?
This is solid-state chemistry.
I think up until now, you've
seen that it's pretty rare
that we use solids in
their pure form.
We usually have mixtures.
So for example, when we studied
glasses, we modified
the glasses with an alkaline
earth oxide.
Well we, in fact, were
making a solution of
more than one component.
So it's to get certain
properties
that we study solutions.
Secondly, coming out of liquid
phase is a way to make solids.
So in terms of processing, we
need to understand something
about solutions.
And then lastly, we're going
to be studying, towards the
end of the semester, a big
unit on biochemistry.
And biochemistry, why, you
say, biochemistry?
Why is he doing biochemistry?
I thought this was solid-state
chemistry.
We are solid-state devices, but
we're made of soft matter.
At least the exoskeleton
is soft matter.
The endoskeleton is
ceramic, right?
Our bone structure is ceramic.
Hydroxyapatite, calcium
hydroxyapatite, and the
outside is a polymer.
So look at this.
Confirmational changes
in polymer.
But the chemistry, the
biochemistry, so much of it
takes place in aqueous
solution.
So hence, we better
know something
about aqueous solution.
So to this, we go almost right
back to the first day.
You remember, was the second
lecture, and we showed this
figure, and all the different
categories of matter.
And we started over here with
elements, and we moved into
some pure substance compounds,
et cetera, et cetera.
Now we're going to move
over to here.
So homogeneous mixture
containing uniform composition
and properties, as opposed
to a heterogeneous mix.
So we're now over here.
We're working our way
through the diagram.
All right.
So let's get a couple of
basic definitions up.
So the solution is really
a mix of at least two
constituents.
One, the majority constituent
is called the solvent, and
then we can have one
or more solutes.
So the solvent, this is the
majority constituent, and then
the solutes are the minority
constituents.
And in some instances,
it's pretty hard to
tell which is which.
And as far as types
of solutions, I
want to broaden this.
You know, when I say solution,
you're probably thinking about
aqueous solution.
But I want to take a minute and
work through this chart.
And this is all posted,
so you don't have to
write it all down.
Just follow with me.
So most of the general chemistry
subjects will just
stop at the end of
the first line.
They'll treat solutions
as aqueous solutions.
But in material science, we
think of things broadly.
So a good example of a simple
aqueous solution is sodium
chloride and water.
Sodium chloride is the solute
and water is the solvent.
But you can have a
liquid solute.
So wine--
in case you've ever encountered
this beverage,
it's primarily water, but it
can contain up to about 14%
ethyl alcohol, and there are
other constituents that give
the color and the flavor
and so on.
And you can have a gas in a
liquid, and that would be
seltzer, where CO2
is dissolved.
It's actually dissolved.
If you take a look at a bottle
of bubbly water on the shelf,
you don't see the bubbles.
The carbon dioxide is
actually dissolved.
You can have a gas as a solvent,
and air would be an
example of that, where the
solvent is nitrogen.
And then we have as solutes
oxygen, argon, carbon dioxide,
if you live next to a power
plant, it's sulfur dioxide, if
you live next to an aluminum
smelter, it's
tetrafluoromethane, and so on.
So we have all kinds of
solutes in the air.
And then we can have
solid solutions.
And OK, as soon as you see the
word solid, you know, that
means you're 3.091.
So what do we see for solids?
Metal alloys.
We saw carbon dissolved
in iron.
Well, that's a solution.
It's homogeneous, single phase,
just as the definition
on that chart 1.11 said.
Semiconductor, boron doping into
silicon, the boron sits
on a silicon lattice site.
So this is a true solution.
The boron is the solute, and
silicon is the solvent.
We can have the ceramic.
We talked about the
oxygen sensor.
The oxygen sensor is zirconia,
which has been stabilized with
the addition of calcium oxide.
As one example.
In contemporary work, they
might use another oxide.
But what's the purpose
of the calcium oxide?
Well, I told you that it's
to increase the vacancy
population, give you
a rapid response
on your oxygen sensor.
And as we're going to learn
later, that's true, and
there's a second value in
putting in the calcium oxide.
And it stabilizes, that's why
they use the term stabilize,
it stabilizes the cubic
form of zirconia.
Zirconia has a different
crystallographic
modifications.
The cubic one is the one that
gives us the best ability to
transfer oxygen, and the
addition of calcium oxide as a
solute, the calcium ions
actually sit on the zirconium
lattice, that's a true
solid solution.
It also makes the cubic zirconia
stable, and with
Christmas coming, you know, it's
the poor man's diamond,
and that's the same
material there.
And to modify a glass, as I
mentioned earlier, adding a
alkaline earth oxide breaks
the silicate network.
That's a solution.
Now here's an inverse one,
where the solid is the
solvent, and the liquid
is the solute.
So this was dentist's office
practice going back to the
time when I was your age.
If you had a feeling, the
dentist had silver and mercury
in the dentist's office, and
would add liquid mercury to
silver and make up this amalgam,
and then jam that
into the tooth.
Actually, that was the B
part of the operation.
There was this dentist here in
the United States, and if I
could find him, I would like
to have a word with him.
But he had this theory.
You see, the amalgam is
a metallic alloy.
And so obviously, it has
metallic bonding.
And the tooth is--
it's a ceramic.
So what kind of bonds are going
to form between a metal
and a ceramic?
They're not very good.
So this dentist had the theory
that the way to increase the
bonding capability of the
amalgam to the tooth was to
maximize contact areas.
So when you went in with a tiny,
tiny little cavity, the
dentist would drill the tooth
out, removing about 75% of the
volume of the tooth, and then
they would make this amalgam
and shove that in.
And you'd wear that for about
20 years, until one day you
bite into a muffin that's got a
little piece of walnut shell
in it, and the amalgam
flexes, and your
thin-walled tooth goes bang!
Like that.
And now you get to go back to
the dentist's office for yet
some more medieval treatment.
Actually, things have
improved somewhat.
Thanks to material science.
But they're not using this
amalgam anymore.
But there are a number of us who
are still walking around
with silver and mercury
in our mouths, and--
yeah.
Enough about my dental
problems.
Now let's go on to
intercalation.
You can put a gas
into a solid.
And I told you about this one,
where if you want to store
hydrogen, and this is a big
problem, if we're going to
talk about hydrogen-powered
vehicles.
A problem as big as, how to
get the fuel cell cheap
enough, is where are you going
to store the hydrogen on the
car, and one of the materials
that's been proposed is this
alloy of lanthanum and nickel
that can intercalate huge
amounts of hydrogen.
So that forms a solid
solution.
So those are examples of
solutions, and we're going to
go back and make sure that we
cover the basic Gen Chem at
the top here.
But I want you know
that solution
chemistry is very broad.
Now when you dissolve something,
you actually have
things down at the
atomic level.
So for example, in brine, you
actually have below two
nanometers as particle size.
You actually have sodium ions
and chloride ions dissolved
completely, which means that
the solution is clear,
colorless, and transparent
to visible light.
Water is clear, colorless,
transparent to visible light.
If you had sodium chloride, it
remains clear, colorless,
transparent to visible light.
You can't filter, and you can't
wait for the sodium
chloride to settle out, because
it's bonded within the
structure of the liquid water.
And this has implications.
There's so much water on the
planet, but there's not so
much fresh water
on the planet.
And desalination can't be
accomplished by filtration.
A filter that had a pore size
small enough to trap sodium
ions, the pore size would be
so small, water molecules
couldn't go through.
So this is the concept.
At the other end, you can get
something called a suspension,
where the particle size is
greater than about 1,000
nanometers, and blood is a good
example of that, where
it's opaque.
Visible light doesn't go
through, but you can filter
out some of the matter
in blood.
And if you let it sit for a
while, it'll settle in it
gravitational field.
And in between, you have this
whole zone of colloids.
And so between colloids and
suspensions, the only
difference is particle size.
And this whole thing we would
just call a dispersion of
another phase, either another
solid phase, or
another liquid phase.
And it's kind of an interesting
physical chemistry
about the dispersion,
what makes it work.
For example, in milk, milk
is a good example of a
dispersion.
You have a fatty phase, and
you have an aqueous phase.
The aqueous phase, where
all the minerals are.
Why?
Because the minerals are--
what kind of compound?
They're not metallic, they're
not covalent.
They're ionic.
The ionic compounds dissolve in
the aqueous phase, and then
in the fatty phase, that's
where you have the
protein and so on.
But the fatty phase is clear and
colorless, and the aqueous
phase is clear and colorless.
And yet milk is white.
It's, as the term implies,
it's milky.
Why?
What's going on?
You have a second phase here.
This could be the fatty phase,
and this is the aqueous phase.
They're both clear and
colorless, but they have
different indices
of refraction.
And since this has n fatty
phase, and this has n aqueous
phase, this interface
scatters the light.
So if you want to start a
business, if you want to try
to tailor the index so that the
index of the aqueous phase
matches the index of refraction
of the fatty phase,
you'd have the two dissolve,
one and the other, and it
would be transparent,
divisible light.
So you would have milk
that isn't milky.
I mean, the public would
be very confused.
But anyways.
So that's what you do.
So why does this thing
not settle?
Because they do have a density
difference, and again, going
back to the days when I was not
a college student but a
youngster, there was still
this form of milk called
pasteurized milk.
Well, all milk is pasteurized,
but this milk was not
homogenized.
And what would happen is, there
was this person that
would deliver milk.
This was a borosilicate
glass bottle.
And here would be the cream.
The cream would rise
to the top.
We have all these expressions
in our language.
And then this would be the milk
here, and you could skim
this off for coffee or sugar,
and then this would be a
low-fat milk.
But people wanted this all
mixed, so then they went to
homogenized milk.
So what is homogenized milk?
This is your red cap, now.
All the milk is homogenized.
This was a big thing.
This was simply called
pasteurized.
I'm going to get to the physical
chemistry here.
It's very interesting.
Because this is lower density,
and yet in homogenized milk it
doesn't rise.
So let's take a look at what
goes on in the physical
chemistry of homogenized milk,
because it's all about these
various systems. So I'm going
to take this particle here,
and its sum insoluble cluster.
And I'm not specifying
the cluster size.
It's probably greater than
about two nanometers.
So there are two forces
acting on this.
There's a settling force and
there's a buoyancy force.
Obviously, otherwise
it wouldn't float.
So there's some kind of
a buoyancy force.
Settling force and
Well, the settling force, this
is just the gravity.
Right?
This is the force of gravity.
And we know the force
of gravity.
That goes with the mass.
Come on, get that cell
phone out of here.
This force of gravity goes as
the mass, and the mass, we
know, goes as the volume.
And the volume goes as the
cube of the radius.
I'm assuming this is a spherical
particle, all right?
Now, the buoyancy force.
The buoyancy force is
the interfacial
force between the two.
There's some binding
across here.
Maybe weak van der Waals, or
if this fatty phase has
molecules in it that are polar,
then there could be
dipole-dipole interaction.
But in any case, there's
some kind of an
interfacial force here.
And this is all chemical
bonding
between solute and solvent.
But you see, the force
is a weak force.
If it were a really strong
force, it would
dissolve this thing.
It won't quite dissolve it,
but there is some kind of
dipole-dipole weak force.
And this one here is operating
across the surface area.
That's the contact.
So this force goes as the area,
and area goes as the
square of the radius,
whereas mass goes as
the cube of the radius.
So you know, from your math,
that r cubed dominates r
squared, but only at large r.
It's not always the
case, is it?
Maybe before you got here,
you thought that.
But now that you've been at
MIT a few months, you know
that r squared can dominate
r cubed at small r.
Interfacial forces dominate.
And that's exactly what happens
in these dispersions,
and that's why they
don't settle out.
Now, homogenized milk is simply
milk that has been
agitated in such a way as to
reduce the fat globule size
below a critical value so that
these interfacial forces hold
the fat globules
in suspension.
If you waited long enough, they
would agglomerate and
settle, but that time is
probably longer than the shelf
life of the milk.
So the milk probably spoils
before stuff settles out.
So this is all very important
to understand.
The range that exists between
insolubility and this sort of
clustering, and suspension,
and so on.
By the way, a lot of
pharmaceuticals are like this.
A lot of pharmaceuticals.
So when it says, shake
well before
using, they're not kidding.
Because the active ingredient
will settle.
And you're drinking just the
solvent, just the vehicle.
And all of the potency is on
the bottom of the bottle.
Shake that thing up!
I can't say what it does
to the taste, but
that's another problem.
Actually, I threw in
this slide here.
We're not going to spend any
time on it, but you can look
at it at some point.
This is a whole taxonomy
of colloids.
Solid-liquid emulsions,
aerosols, they're all part of
this magic zone between
solubility and
just brick, all right?
There's this whole fine,
pardon the pun,
the whole fine structure.
OK, So let's get to
the chemistry.
Obviously there's something to
do with bonding here, right?
So here's a simple experiment,
and this is taken right from
the reading.
So I've just taken this episode
that is written up in
the reading.
So we've got two beakers
here, and in each
beaker, we have a bilayer.
We've poured in some carbon
tetrachloride, liquid, and
we've poured in some water.
And these two are immiscible,
because carbon tetrachloride
is obviously a non-polar liquid,
and water is a polar
liquid with hydrogen
bonding capability.
And in one beaker, we introduce
crystals of iodine.
In the other beaker, we
introduce crystals of
potassium permanganate.
And then we shake them
up, and we wait.
And eventually we see that on
the left, the iodine dissolves
in the carbon tetrachloride.
And we're using the purple
color as an indicator.
And this is kind of cute,
because both potassium
permanganate and iodine will
render things purple.
So you're comparing
purple to purple.
They could have chosen something
else, but this is
kind of cute.
All right.
So here you end up with a
solution of iodine and carbon
tetrachloride, whereas on the
right side, you end up with a
solution of potassium
permanganate and water, and
nothing in the carbon
tetrachloride.
So what can we infer
from this?
Well, let's take a look at the
possible interactions.
So first of all let's
categorize H2O.
This is polar, it's a polar
liquid, with hydrogen bonding
capability.
Carbon tetrachloride
is non-polar.
It's very toxic.
When I was a child, we had this
in the medicine cabinet.
It's a non-polar solvent.
It's fantastic for getting
grease stains off.
Every man had this.
With a little handkerchief,
you'd take a little grease
stain off your tie.
You can't buy this stuff.
You can't even guy it for
research anymore.
It's too bad.
It's great stuff.
Highly toxic, though.
But you know, there's
a time and a place.
All right.
So then here's iodine.
Iodine, we know, is non-polar.
It's a homonuclear molecule,
it has to be non-polar.
And so what holds iodine
together in the crystal?
There's only one bond, and
that's van der Waals, right?
It's a van der Waals solid,
whereas potassium permanganate
is an ionic solid.
Potassium permanganate is ionic,
and it consists of
potassium cations and
permanganate anions.
And what we find is that the
non-polar solute dissolves in
the non-polar solvent, and the
ionic solute dissolves in the
polar solvent with hydrogen
bonding capability.
So from this, we can infer the
general rule, which is
encapsulated in the language
used in chemistry textbooks.
Like dissolves like.
And what they're really saying
here, is that like solutes
dissolve in like solvents.
Solute-solvent is like
dissolves like.
OK.
It's a good place to
start, but it's
an incomplete picture.
So I want to show you
that there's some
sophistication here.
This is taken from one
of the other books.
And it shows just the rules for
ionic compounds in water.
And I just showed you, from this
example, that the ionic
compound dissolved in water.
And what you see here is that
some ionic compounds dissolve
in water, but there's
a whole set or
insoluble ionic compounds.
So it's not straightforward.
But we know from 3.091, we know
that we can make sense of
this on the basis
of competition.
Competition between what holds
the compound in the solid
state versus what will pull
it into the liquid state.
So for example, we can compare
sodium chloride, which we know
dissolves in water.
So sodium chloride, as a
crystalline solid, will
dissolve to form sodium chloride
aqueous solution.
Whereas if you look at magnesium
oxide, which is also
an ionic crystal, it does not,
to any standard imaginable,
dissolve to form an aqueous
solution of magnesium oxide.
And what's the difference
here?
The difference here is, compare
solvation energy, in
other words, the energy that you
got by pulling this into
solution, and forming bonds
between sodium and chlorine in
water, with the crystallization
energy.
And what's that all about?
Well, that's the Madelung
constant, remember?
Madelung constant.
q1 q2 over 4 pi epsilon
0 r, where this
is the cation anion.
And you can see here that sodium
chloride has sodium
cations and chloride anions, and
there's a certain binding
energy in the crystal.
Magnesium has 2 plus.
Oxide is 2 minus.
The binding energy between
magnesium and oxygen is so
great that there's no driving
force to dissolve.
Now, I don't expect you to be
able to look at this and tell
me whether something's going
to dissolve or not.
But if I were to say to you,
explain why sodium chloride
forms solutions with water, and
magnesium oxide doesn't,
that you could go through
this rationalization.
And here's a cartoon from the
textbook that tries to
illustrate this solvation.
Here you can see a crystal of
sodium chloride, in the
inimitable fashion, as drawn by
chemistry books, where the
chloride ion is green, and
the sodium ion is blue.
And that's OK.
I can live with the
color-coding, as long as we
agree amongst ourselves, these
ions are clear and colorless,
because they have octet
stability in
their electronic shell.
And here's water, with the
hydrogen shown in white, and
the oxygen shown in red.
And you can see that the oxide
end, the oxygen end, the delta
negative end of the water, is
trying to wrest sodium cation
out of the lattice,
and ultimately
surround it by a cage.
And the same thing here.
You see the hydrogen ends of
the water trying to pull
chloride out, and ultimately
surround it with
a water-like cage.
So this is the competition
I was talking about.
In the case of sodium chloride,
water wins.
In the case of magnesium
oxide, water loses.
The binding energy between
magnesium and oxygen and the
crystal dominate.
So you don't see
that solvation.
OK.
Let's talk about metrics now.
Let's look at some metrics
of solubility.
It's quantifiable.
So we can express a measure of
solubility in terms of a
quantity known as molarity.
So we can express moles of
solute per liter of solvent.
And this is called molarity, and
the symbol is capital M.
So we can say, for example, a
1 molar solution of sodium
chloride in water, we'll write
1 molar NaCl, and then we'll
write subscript aq,
meaning aqueous.
So it's an aqueous solution at
a concentration of 1 mole of
NaCl per liter.
And the liter is named after a
person, so that's capital L,
per liter of solution.
And remember, the solution
is the sum of
the water plus solute.
For dilute solutions, there's
very little difference between
the total amount of water and
the total amount of solution.
But in certain instances, the
presence of the solute
actually has a volumetric
change on here.
So strictly speaking, it's
per liter of solution
And as I've shown you, there
are degrees of solubility.
So people represent the
threshold of solubility as c
of the solute.
When c of the solute is less
than about a million molar,
0.001 molar, we call
this insoluble.
So something is vanishingly
soluble, we
say that's the value.
So we'll call this
the threshold.
And then, something that's quite
soluble, we'd say that
the concentration of the solute
starts to exceed at
about 0.1 molar.
And then we would say, that
qualifies as soluble.
So now let's look at two
extremes in solubility,
operating off of this.
So in the one case, we can
have complete solubility.
So examples of that, where
things are completely miscible
in one another.
Complete solubility.
By the way, some people will
use the term miscibility.
When something is miscible
it means it's soluble.
Same idea.
If something is insoluble, some
people might say it's
immiscible.
Same thing.
OK?
So complete solubility is
ethyl alcohol and water.
You can mix them in
all proportions.
Continuously variable.
On the solid alloy is
silver and gold.
Silver and gold, you can make
alloys of any composition
between 100% gold
and 100% silver.
Now, that's the exception.
Most cases are situations
of limited solubility.
So they go up to a maximum,
which we can denote C-star or
C saturation.
This is the maximum
solubility.
So an example of something
that's sparingly soluble in
water is silver chloride.
Let's look at silver chloride.
So silver chloride, I'm going to
start here, silver chloride
as a crystal, and I'm going
to dissolve that in water.
So that gives me AgCl aq.
So that's just simply the
formation of an aqueous
solution of silver chloride.
And when the reaction moves from
left to right, we call
that dissolution.
The silver chloride is
dissolving, and when the
system moves from right to
left, we call that--
now here I'm going to nitpick
with the book.
The book calls the left reaction
crystallization.
And that's correct.
It is crystallization in this
case, because silver chloride
is a crystal.
But it is possible, in other
systems, to have the solute
come out of solution, and
make a solid that is
noncrystalline.
And you know that all crystals
are solids, but not all solids
are crystals.
You can have an amorphous
solid.
So what would happen if you were
to bring out of solution
an amorphous solid?
It would be silly to call
it crystallization.
So I prefer to use the
term precipitation.
And there's another term that
you can use, and I learned
this one from reading the
literature of geochemistry.
What the geochemists call the
reaction going from solution
to make a solid, they say
the system exsolves.
This is dissolve,
this is exsolve.
So this is called exsolution.
It's amazing what you can
do when you know a
little bit of Latin.
So this exsolves.
So that's the exsolution, or the
crystallization reaction.
Now I'm going to show you what
won Arrhenius his Nobel prize.
Arrhenius did not get the Nobel
prize for his brilliant
work on activation energy.
He got his Nobel prize on the
theory of electrolytic
dissociation, which was, people
knew that you could
dissolve salts and water, but
they didn't know how.
And it was Arrhenius who said
that the salts go into
solution by dissociating
and forming ions.
So goes in as Ag plus Ag plus
aq plus chloride ion--
thank you.
And that, ladies and gentleman,
was a Nobel prize
for Arrhenius.
And you can see that there's
a relationship between the
amount of silver chloride
and the amount of ions.
So there's a mass balance there,
that the concentration
of silver chloride dissolved, in
fact, equals, in this case,
by stoichiometry, the
concentration of Ag plus,
because of the nature of the
dissociation reaction on a
mass balance basis.
And that also equals the
concentration of the
chloride ion, OK?
So that's the way we can
look at the system.
And how do we know that this
thing has limited solubility?
Well, there's various ways of
measuring it, and one of them
involves conductivity.
Here's the conductivity
of pure water.
And you know that water has
very, very poor conductivity,
and in fact, what's happening
here, when we add silver
chloride is, we're adding charge
carriers, because the
audience are charged species.
So they can carry charge.
And you can see that this is a
measure of conductivity as a
function of silver chloride
concentration.
And as you add silver chloride
to higher and higher values,
the conductivity goes up.
And look at even the tiniest
amount of silver chloride has
a conductivity that's about,
what, half an order of
magnitude higher than
the conductivity
of pure water itself.
So I would say that this is
akin to doping, isn't it?
So up here, when you've got 10
to the minus 6 Siemens per
centimeter conductivity, that
aqueous solution is
demonstrating the extrinsic
behavior.
This is very similar
to doping.
And at some point, we get to
this value here, around 10 to
the minus 5 moles of silver
chloride per liter, and then
adding more silver chloride has
no impact on conductivity.
Which tells you that you've
hit saturation.
This is akin to adding more and
more sugar to the cup of
tea, until finally the sugar
just falls to the bottom.
You can stir all you want, but
you won't get it to dissolve,
because you've hit saturation.
So that indicates the presence
of a saturated solution.
And so we can talk about that
value, and we can say that for
silver chloride, the
concentration at saturation is
equal to 1.3 times 10 to the
minus 5 moles per liter.
Moles of silver chloride
per liter.
And obviously, that's equal to,
according to that, it's
equal to the silver
ion concentration.
I'm going to use square brackets
to indicate moles of
silver, ion per liter
of solution, which
is also equal to--
pardon me-- it's also equal to
the chloride ion concentration
at saturation.
Now I'm going to ask you
a simple question.
Suppose I've got a beaker here,
and I know the maximum I
can get here, the maximum is 1.3
times 10 to the minus 5.
Now this is a really
simple question.
Suppose I am about to add
silver chloride--
let's say this is
1 liter already.
All right?
I've got one liter.
And you'd tell me, well, you can
put in 1.3 times 10 to the
minus 5 moles to get
the saturation.
Suppose instead of 1 liter of
pure water, I had 1 liter of
water already containing, say,
1 times 10 to the minus 5
molar silver chloride.
Well, that's kind of
obvious, isn't it?
I'm only going to be able to put
0.3 moles in, because 0.3
times 10 to the minus 5, because
I've already got
silver chloride in there.
That's easy.
Now let's make the question
a little more interesting.
Suppose instead of a certain
amount of silver chloride in
there, I have no silver
chloride in there.
But I've got, say, 0.1 molar
sodium chloride.
It's a salt.
It's a difference salt.
So the question is, does the
presence of a different salt
have an impact on how much
silver chloride I can put into
this solution?
And the answer is, yes.
The answer is yes.
So what we find is that the
presence of the other salt, in
this case, has an impact,
because sodium chloride goes
in as sodium plus, and
chloride minus.
So there's already a boatload of
chloride ion in there, and
that has an impact on
this relationship.
So how do we answer the
question, what is the
solubility of silver chloride
in the presence of other
chloride ions?
And for that, we define
something called the
solubility product.
And you need it in order to
answer the question, how do
you determine the solubility
of a solute when there are
other solutes present already?
And it's denoted capital K,
lowercase sp, subscript.
Solubility product.
And it's equal to simply
the ion products of the
constituents.
So the solubility product of
silver chloride is the product
of the silver ion concentration,
and the
chloride ion concentration.
And you know that in a solution
of silver chloride
alone, if nothing else, that
the concentration of silver
ion equals the concentration
of chloride ion.
That's the whole business
of dissolving by itself.
And so I can then just
say that Ksp.
will then equal the
concentration of silver ion
squared, which we also know is
equal to the concentration of
silver chloride aqueous.
See, all of these
are the same.
So this solubility
is the same.
I can just put that in, which
is just concentration of
silver chloride.
Square that.
So if I square 1.3 times 10 to
the minus 5, I end up with a
solubility product of 1.8 times
10 to the minus 10.
So now I can use this in order
to determine how much
solubility I get in the presence
of another salt.
So in this case, I'm going to
put 0.1 molar sodium chloride.
And these are strong salts, so
we're going to get complete
dissociation.
Gives me 0.1 molar sodium ion,
and 0.1 molar chloride ion,
when it dissociates.
Now you see the difference.
Because the silver chloride, by
itself, gives me 10 to the
minus 5 molar chloride ions.
When I add sodium chloride,
I get 4 as a
magnitude more chloride.
So let's go back to the Ksp.
So Ksp, this is for
silver chloride.
Ksp for silver chloride is
going to be equal to the
silver concentration and the
chloride concentration.
And in this case, the silver
concentration is just equal to
whatever that solubility is.
Because there's only source
of silver ion,
and it's silver chloride.
So I can write that as
concentration of silver chloride.
That's good.
And now this one here is what?
I've got two sources.
I've got silver chloride, I
I've got sodium chloride.
So it's going to equal
this thing here.
0.1 plus whatever I get
from silver chloride.
And it's vanishingly
small, isn't it?
The concentration of silver
chloride, whatever it is.
This is nothing, so I'm just
going to neglect it.
It's dominated now.
The chlorine is flooded by
the silver chloride.
And this product
is a constant.
That's still equal to
10 to the minus 10.
So I can turn this around and
solve for the concentration of
silver chloride, which
is equal to the
concentration of silver io.
And that's equal to, what is
it, 10 to of the minus 10
divided by 0.1, which
then gives me--
what's the number here?
Plug that in.
And I end up with 10
to the 1.8 times 10
to the minus 9 molar.
Right?
So look.
Look at what's happened by
having the chloride present
from sodium chloride in
such a large amount.
It's repressed.
It has repressed the
dissolution.
The presence of chloride then
has a negative impact on
solubility, and instead of
having 10 to the minus 5
molar, it's down to 10 to
the the minus 9 molar.
And this effect of repressing
solubility by adding a second
solute is called the common
ion effect, OK?
Solubility repression by second
solute is known as the
common ion effect.
And this is used
in processing.
If I want to trigger
the precipitation--
see, if I started with a
solution containing 10 to the
minus 5 molar of silver
chloride, and I throw in some
sodium chloride, it'll start
precipitating out silver chloride.
So if I wanted to make a fine
precipitate of silver
chloride, I make a pregnant
solution.
And I could drop the
temperature, because you can
imagine that solubility is a
function of temperature, or I
could keep it isothermal, throw
in some sodium chloride,
and out comes silver chloride.
So since the common ion effect
on it and its value in
processing.
OK.
Good.
Well, I think I'm going
to hold it there.
I"ll show you just
one more thing.
If you've got stoichiometry
like this--
this is a difluoride
of magnesium.
If it goes into solution, you
get magnesium cation plus 2
fluoride anions.
And so if I wrote the Ksp for
this reaction, it would be the
product of the magnesium
concentration and the fluoride
ion concentration.
Because there's the two
here, this is squared.
So this, too, will transfer up
there, and then throw in some
sodium fluoride, and cause the
other thing to exsolve, and
away we go.
All right.
I've got a couple of
things to show you.
We're talking a lot
about Arrhenius.
This is a book I have. It's an
English translation of a book
written by Arrhenius in the late
1800s, and it was printed
in English around 1908.
And Arrhenius was a genius.
He wrote on all sorts
of topics here.
Biology, physics, you name it.
And one of the things and he
was interested in was the
origins of the earth.
So this chapter is called,
Celestial Bodies as Abodes of
Organisms. Already speculating
on whether you could have life
as we know it exist elsewhere
in the universe.
And one of the things he talks
about is global warming.
So this is Arrhenius
on global warming.
I'll read you the last paragraph
of this chapter.
There had been some major
volcanic eruptions that had
caused cooling when Krakatoa
in 1883 and
Martinique in 1902.
Major plumes of soot that caused
dramatic decreases in
temperature.
So now here comes the
last paragraph.
We often hear lamentations that
the coal stored up in the
earth is wasted by the
present generation--
remember, this is written
100 years ago--
without any thought
of the future.
And we are terrified by the
awful destruction of life and
property which is followed the
volcanic eruptions of our day.
We may find a kind of
consolation in the
consideration that adheres
in every other case.
There is good mixed
with the evil.
By the influence of the
increasing percentage of
carbonic acid in the
atmosphere-- that's CO2--
we may hope to enjoy ages with
more equitable and better
climates.--
Remember, he's a Swede;
it's cold--
especially as regards the colder
regions of the earth,
ages when the earth will bring
forth much more abundant crops
than at present for
the benefit of
rapidly propagating mankind.
So it's interesting
to see the world--
it's a great book to read.
And you can see people in the
1830s were already calculating
heat transfer coefficients
to how much
the earth was changing.
We're going to post these
to the website.
This was, last year, in
the New York Times.
Every Tuesday they have
a science section.
And this was about glass.
And very, actually, with your
3.091 knowledge, you'll read
this like a newspaper, and
it'll be very easy.
And they go through
the structure.
Here's the structure
of a window glass.
You can see the network,
former network
modifier, and so on.
And they talk about how
difficult it is from a first
principle's standpoint to model
the structure of glass.
These oxide glasses are complex
and not easy to model.
So when you're trying to
engineer the glasses, instead
of trial and error, it's hard
to do so by theory.
And it talks about some efforts
at theory, and so on.
And the last thing I want
to talk about is
bulk metallic glasses.
You recall that I showed you
metallic glass that was made
by melting gold silicon,
and dripping it onto a
water-cooled copper wheel that
was zooming around to give us
a cooling rate of about a
million degrees a second.
And those strips had
to be very, very
thin, the metal strips.
Because you've got liquid
dripping down, and we're
pulling the solid away,
and there's a
finite thickness here.
Let's use a Greek letter, xi.
There's a finite thickness xi.
Because what's happening is that
this is the water-cooled
copper wheel, and you're
extracting heat here.
But eventually, the thermal
conductivity of the metal is
the limiter.
In other words, I don't
care how cold.
You can put this in liquid
helium if you want.
You can't get the heat through
the metal fast enough.
And what happens is, when you
look down here, the lower part
is amorphous and the upper
part is crystalline.
So you don't end up with
metallic glass.
You end up with some metallic
glass, and the upper part is
crystalline.
So what happens when you end up
with the limitation being
the thermal conductivity
of the metal?
At that point, you're
finished.
And this was typically on
the order of microns.
And then they got up to,
sort of, submillimeter.
And that was it.
So the glass that I showed
you was foil.
Now what happened was,
with more research--
so here we are.
This is Pol Duwez at Caltech,
gold silicon.
And this is the thickness
in centimeters.
So you were down here at some
tens of microns, all right?
Now, in the '60s, research at
Harvard uncovered a set of
palladium alloys that had better
thermal conductivity
and, remember the first day,
about the analogy to the
musical chairs?
These things have slightly
more complicated crystal
structures.
So for a given cooling rate, the
metal has more difficulty
finding the proper
lattice site.
And they were able to make
metallic glasses that were on
the order of 0.1 centimeters.
That's still fairly thin.
And then back to Caltech in the
late '80s, early '90s, and
a man by name of Bill Johnson
was able to develop a set of
alloys that can be made
in bulk form.
Totally amorphous metal.
And these are known as bulk
metallic glasses.
And look at the complexity
of the alloy designation.
So now you see, well, why
are they doing this?
Because look, this is strength
versus elastic limit.
So you can either have things
like polymers, that you can
stretch very, very far, but they
don't have much strength.
Or you can have things like
certain steels, that are very,
very strong, but you can't
bend them very far.
And bulk metallic glass has
put you right up here.
You have strong alloys
that have very, very
high elastic limits.
So they make great golf clubs
and tennis rackets and so on,
because they can flex way back,
store enormous energy,
and then spring.
So here are some bulk metallic
glasses, and
here's a classic one.
This is zirconium, titanium,
copper, nickel, beryllium.
All right, now how
do we get that?
Well, zirconium and titanium are
body-centered cubic, we've
got copper and nickel are
face-centered cubic, and
beryllium is hexagonal
close-packed.
So the idea here is the
principle of confusion.
So the alloy is fighting
with itself.
You know, am I face-centered
cubic, am I body-centered
cubic, am I hexagonal?
And this confusion about what
the crystal structure is to be
leads to quenching and the
disorder of a liquid state,
and preventing the formation
of grain boundaries,
dislocations and so on.
So I want to show you one
example besides golf clubs.
Dave, could we cut to the
document camera here?
Get this thing down.
So this is a--
I'm not endorsing the product at
all, but you know, this is
one of the companies
that makes, this
is SanDisk, I think.
And they make these
flash memories.
This just looks like a another
piece of metal, and in fact,
it's very disarming,
because they call
this model the Titanium.
Well, it has about
13% titanium.
The interesting thing here,
what's so cool about this,
this is bulk metallic glass.
And what's attractive about
the fact that it's bulk
metallic glass is, that it can
be shaped by casting, from the
liquid state to very,
very fine precision.
So you see all of these slots
and everything, and on the
side, all of this kind of
stuff, and on the end.
All of this is done by casting
from the liquid
state, in one operation.
And this is a clam shell.
There's two pieces here.
I don't know if you can see,
but there's two pieces that
have been sandwiched together.
You can see on the edge there.
And the impact that has on
manufacturing costs is
phenomenal, because normally
you make the basic shells,
then you have to drill,
and you've got to
auger out, and so on.
This thing, one step operation,
including the labeling.
There's no subsequent
processing.
And this is done by a company
out in Michigan
called Liquid Metal.
And they've licensed the
technology and so on.
And again, I'm not trying to
make a commercial thing, but
I'm just trying to show you that
these ideas of changing
properties for engineered
materials, you know, are
around us everywhere.
And this is relatively recent.
Bulk metallic glass.
Fantastic example of structure
property relations.
OK.